welcome back to las vegas now babies
bounty supports at-risk families by
providing education and essential tools
to ensure a good start for every baby
and one of their more important
resources is their diaper bank program
and here to tell us more about it is the
executive director of babies bounty
kelly maxwell kelly thanks for being
here yes thank you thank you so much for
having me and happy new year happy new
year and this is a big year for you guys
let's just talk about baby's bounty
everything you do and then we'll get to
all the exciting stuff you have coming
up this year absolutely so we're 13 year
old nonprofit working to improve health
outcomes for uh families with newborns
in southern nevada
uh we started that with our baby bundle
program so this program has assisted
over 8 000 families so far
so families in need qualify and they
receive everything you see here wow
brand new portable crib brand new car
seat all of the items needed to care for
a newborn for the first six months of
life
infant bathtub washcloths toiletry items
diapers wipes
safe sleep kit bibs rattles feeding
supplies everything you'd need wow this
i'm sure it makes the process a little
bit easier for new parents and i can
only imagine how incredible this would
be to receive this and let's talk about
the process of it and where you get
these items from and how everything
works yeah so we partner with 120
partner agencies so you just need a
referral you need to qualify within 130
percent of the federal poverty
guidelines once we receive that referral
you take our newborn education class and
we can get this ready within a week wow
okay a quick turnaround that's pretty
amazing we know they need those items
and get them right away something else
they really need i know diapers are
everything so let's talk about the
program and what you guys do so when
covid hit our clients who had previously
received baby bundles were calling they
couldn't find diapers on the shelves
the supply chain issues were causing a
big a big problem and if they were able
to to find the diapers they couldn't
afford them they were out of work
waiting for unemployment 11 12 weeks so
we launched a diaper bank we helped 63
families the first week oh my gosh
congratulations and now
so in november we celebrated 1 million
diapers 3 million wipes to over 18 000
southern nevadans that is absolutely
incredible and i feel like you guys are
only just getting started let's talk
about what's new in 2022 we're so
excited so our long-term goal was to
create a mobile diaper bank
we were noticing that our clients
were experiencing transportation issues
so we wanted to solve the transportation
problem for them so
we had an amazing year and with some
great community support we just placed
an order for a mobile diaper bank oh my
gosh congratulations i think that's
going to make a huge difference in our
community and we're also just showing
some photos on the screen there of the
community really coming together in
support how does it feel to know that
you know you're going into the 13th year
that you're continuing to make a
difference in lives and families who
really need it sure well i'm a local
born and raised
it's the greatest honor of my lifetime
to be able to help my community on this
scale so we're going to continue to
support families in need in southern
nevada
we're going to solve diaper need in
southern nevada by 2025
and we're going to start with this
mobile diaper bank well congratulations
i think 2022 is going to be your guys
year and if people want to get involved
or help or need your assistance where do
they go babiesbounty.org they can find
all the ways to help we have volunteer
opportunities there's donation
opportunities
folks prefer to donate cash it's easier
for them we have that portal on our
website
we always accept new unopened diapers as
long as um they're size four five and
six at this point we need the larger
sizes okay that's all great to know
kelly thank you so much congratulations
thank you for being here rocky i'll send
it over to you thank you baby on